some of us think holding on makes us
strong
but sometimes it is Letting Go
to achieve the possible
we must attempt The Impossible again
and again
knowledge can be communicated but not
wisdom
you can find it live it
and you can listen to these quotes by
Hermann Hess to learn how to communicate
and teach true life wisdom
love your suffering
do not resist it
do not flee from it
it is only your aversion to it that
hurts
nothing else
faith in doubt go hand in hand
they are complementaries
one who never doubts will never truly
believe
ends when egotism does
maturity begins when one lives for
others
theory is knowledge that doesn't work
practice is when everything works
and you don't know why
when you like someone you like them in
spite of their faults
when you love someone
you love them with their faults
loneliness is the way by which Destiny
Endeavors to lead man to himself
fate and character are different names
for the same idea
only the thoughts that we live have
value
a house without love is a poor house
even if beautiful rugs are covering its
floors and precious wallpapers and
pictures
cover its walls
you are only afraid if you are not in
harmony with yourself
happiness is a how not a what
a talent not an object
the true profession of a man is to find
his way to himself
Solitude is independence
people with courage in character
always seem Sinister to the rest
opinions mean nothing
they may be beautiful or ugly clever or
foolish
anyone can Embrace or reject them
everything becomes a little different as
soon as it is spoken out loud
the deity is within you
not in ideas and books
truth is lived not taught
in every truth the opposite is equally
true
a truth can only be expressed and
enveloped in words
if it is one-sided
a higher humor begins with ceasing to
take oneself seriously
each man's life represents a road
towards himself
an attempt at such a road the intimation
of a path
no man has ever been entirely and
completely himself
seriousness is an accident of time
it consists of putting too high of value
on time
in eternity there is no time
eternity is a moment
just long enough for a joke
everyone can reach his goal
if he can think dream and wait
you must find your dream
no matter how old you may be
then the way becomes easy
chaos demands to be recognized and
experienced before letting itself be
converted into a new order
one never reaches home
but wherever friendly paths intersect
the whole world looks like home for a
Time
if we can make a person happier and more
cheerful
we should do it anyway
whether he asks us or not
study from yourself be your own teacher
and your own student
what many people call passion is not
spiritual Force
but friction between the soul and the
outside world
those who cannot think or take
responsibility for themselves
need and clamor for a leader
you should not make a gift for yourself
you are too expensive
you must be one
we can understand one another
but each of us can only interpret
ourselves
seeking means
to have a goal but finding means to be
free
to be receptive
to have no goal
man is an onion consisting of hundreds
of skins
a fabric consisting of many threads
every politician in the world is all for
revolution reason
and disarmament
but only in enemy countries
not in his own
it is not our purpose to become each
other
it is to recognize each other
to learn to see the other
and honor him for what he is
no one marries for the sake of having
children however
when a person has children they will
force him to change
and in the end he will see that
everything was done
only for them
lack of friends is a sign that a man has
many hobbies
as well as time
those who are too lazy and comfortable
to think for themselves and be their own
judges obey the laws
others sense
their own laws within them
words do not express thoughts very well
they always become a little different
immediately after they are expressed
a little distorted a little foolish
so think more and talk less
we have collected these quotes by an
author Hermann Hess whose quotes are the
mirror which allows us to examine our
own identity in a world which has become
more materialistic
and in which we tend to look for
temporary pleasures